IKAI LAN: Hey everyone.
Welcome to another edition of
YouTube Developers Live.
We have a very special show
for you guys today.
I know I always say that, but
I actually mean that.
First off, let's take a look
at our fine crew today.
Now, if there's something that
you're seeing that's
different, it's that there
are seven of us.
So we have had the entire
developer relations team from
all around the world, and that
means Mountain View, New York,
here in our New York studio
today to talk to you guys
about some of our favorite
moments from the last year of
YouTube Developers Live.
And in addition, we have two
very, very special guests.
People that you haven't seen
on this show before.
One is Amanda, our
glorious leader.
And Darryl, who's our
summer intern.
So why don't we go ahead and
go around the room and all
introduce ourselves for the
viewers, just in case they
don't already know who we are.
I am Ikai Lan.
I'm a member of YouTube
Devleoper Relations, obviously.
Let's not state the obvious.
And I work here in
New York City.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Ibrahim Ulukaya.
I'm also New York city based.
And I'm sure you guys
have seen me in
New York City before.
So I'll hand it to Darryl.
DARRYL: Hi, I'm Darryl.
I'm the summer intern, and
I work in Mountain View.
I'm a rising junior at Stanford,
and I'm working on a
top secret project.
AMANDA: Hi, I'm Amanda, and I'm
based in Silicon Valley.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I'm
Jarek, based in
Silicon Valley as well.
JEFF POSNICK: I'm Jeff.
And I'm based here
in New York.
JEREMY: And I'm Jeremy.
And I'm also based in
Silicon Valley.
IKAI LAN: So as I mentioned,
today we're going to be
showing you guys our favorite
moments from YouTube
Developers Live.
So all of us have gone out and
picked out a short clip from
our favorite show.
In many of the cases,
we are in the shows.
So just putting that
out there.
Why don't we go ahead and
get started, Jeff?
I believe you're up first.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
Thanks, you guys.
So yeah, I was a little biased
in choosing my clip.
This is a show that I was in.
Its an interview that I did a
few months back with John
Luther, who's one of the product
managers for WebM and
for VP8, and a lot of the really
cool video and coding
technology that we use at
Google and YouTube.
And in addition to being what
I think was a really great
show, I think it's a
really great topic.
So I hope folks go back and
check out the full video
afterwards.
But we're going to show a
short clip in which John
reveals some of the secret
history behind VP8.
And it goes back a little bit
further than you'd think.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Get into a little bit more of
the details as to why somebody
would actually want to use WebM
and VP8 versus some of
the other formats and codecs
that are out there.
What are some advantages?
-Well, one of the advantages
with VP8 is that it's a very,
very efficient codec.
I mean, it was developed
roughly 2009-ish.
And then we acquired
it in 2010.
So.
-I was expecting you to
say 2,000 years ago.
It's a very ancient codec.
-Not that long.
-Lots of papyrus, hardware
acceleration, stuff like that.
-We were drawing the pixels
by hand when I
first started in this.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JEFF POSNICK: So there you go.
Now you know.
And I'm going to hand things
over to Amanda.
AMANDA: All right.
So one of my favorite shows in
the session is basically the
opening session from this year's
Google I/O, where our
product leader and our
engineering leader articulated
the areas of investment in the
YouTube platform that presents
a lot of opportunities for
developers to innovate and to
leverage the YouTube platform
to grow their business.
So let's watch a clip from
that session right now.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So this is the first time we're
actually doing this and
actually consciously thinking
about, what are some of the
segments we're excited about?
So the labels are still rough,
but I'll try to explain them.
In the top left is creation.
You saw things like live
streaming and capture.
It's very exciting for us.
We'll walk you through
some examples,
including a guest star.
On the discovery and context
side, these are the true
viewer consumption
oriented apps.
So folks like BuzzFeed, who
might be all about news and
really interesting moments.
They are now integrating
video fluidly.
So to keep engagement
in their apps high.
Then we have folks on
the enterprise side.
So enterprise is very hot right
now, partially because
there's a lot of money
flowing to it.
But also, when we look to the
future, we think about tens,
if not hundreds, of $100 million
run rate business
being born on our platform.
And in order to do that, we need
platform companies out
there who are building
on our APIs to
service those verticals.
So we'll talk--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AMANDA: All right.
So if you are a developer
looking for ideas and examples
of what people have done on
the YouTube platform,
definitely check the show up.
And definitely contact one
of us to get started.
And now, Darryl, do you
want to talk about
your favorite show?
DARRYL: Sure.
So one of my favorite
presentations was actually the
Topics API presentation.
So why don't we roll the
video first, and I'll
talk about it afterward.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So not just to talk about what
you can do with these
narrow entities.
But I actually kind of want to
show you what is possible with
the central annotations
that we have today.
I'm not going to talk about
what the demo does
before I go into it.
But you should know that this
is not the rules-based demo.
That is, it's agnostic about
what kind of entity I'm
couriering for.
And it's about maybe
60 lines of Python.
So say, for example, I want to
explore origami on YouTube.
I don't know what origami is
about, except it's about
folding paper.
But I want to learn more.
So I look up the entity
on Freebase.
And how are videos categorized
if I use entities?
Well, it turns out that origami
on YouTube tends to be
different shapes of organisms.
And I can use this to learn
how to fold origami.
So I can start learning
folding roses, cats.
And after I've spent enough time
indoors folding origami,
maybe I want to go outside
and travel a little bit.
So I want to look up,
what do we have
about travel on YouTube?
Probably videos, categorized
into countries and cities.
And sure enough, we have travel
videos about different
countries, and different
cities, and so on.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JEFF POSNICK: That LoCo Host,
man, that's like my favorite
website too.
DARRYL: So in that clip,
Philippe demonstrated the
kinds of apps you can develop
with the YouTube Topics API.
And I really like this
presentation because of two
main reasons.
First, it shows you the power
of the YouTube Topics API.
So in the app he developed, can
search for a keyword, and
it will return a list of search
results grouped by a
secondary topic such as
travel destination.
And I think the Topics API
really opens up a lot of
possibilities for developers
who are interested in using
semantic data.
And second of all, they
explained the ranking
mechanism that YouTube uses in
order to generate the topics
for each video.
So we use three main things.
We use text annotations.
We use audiovisual
data from videos.
And we also use comments data
to generate these topics for
each video.
And the result is that US
developers get concise and
accurate lists of topics
for each video to
use as semantic data.
So I recommend that anyone
interested in using semantic
data for videos takes
a look at the video.
And with that, I'll pass
it off to Jeremy.
JEREMY: Great.
So actually, mine took place
in space and underwater.
So why don't we roll the clip
and then I'll answer.
IKAI LAN: This is going to be a
tough act to follow, Jeremy.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-This is what they
were showing.
And you can actually click.
So let's say I'm in space now,
but I want to be underwater.
I just click, and see, it takes
me now to an underwater.
So this is using your
APIs, correct?
-Yeah, this is using the API.
So from this app, we can
retrieve the first image of
the different video files
that are loaded into the
application.
And then, when you click here
on the top of it, it sends a
message to our FTPI, which
triggers a switch of the
background.
-Yeah.
Yeah, this is really cool.
And of course, our favorite
YouTube dev sticker.
-And then, this is all happening
in real time.
We're doing all this
processing only
by using our software.
So it's in a very
powerful tool.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JEREMY: OK, maybe there is
a couple more in there.
JEFF POSNICK: It looks like
my wallpaper at home.
Just the YouTube Developers
logo.
JEREMY: Yeah, I actually
was plugging the
stickers quite a bit there.
So that was one of our
partners, Cappella's,
students, who actually uses our
new live streaming API.
And they did a really
good job with it.
And we actually did feature them
also at Google I/O and
our YouTube sandbox.
And they did some really cool
things with software, doing
the green screen while they're
streaming to YouTube, using
that live streaming API.
So I just wanted people to see
that it was one of the cool
things we had at I/O.
So with that, I'll
turn it over to Jarek.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Thanks, Jeremy.
All right, so I picked a show
about the YouTube Android
player API.
In fact, it was a very difficult
decision for me
which show to pick.
Because I think we've all done
a lot of interesting shows in
the last few quarters.
A lot of new APIs have
been launched.
And we interviewed a lot
of wonderful partners.
But let's roll the tape, and
then we'll talk a little bit
about that show.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The video wall is an example
of what you might be able to
do with the app, by
putting all the
components of the API together.
And so it's a simple demo
of thumbnails flipping.
And then, one of the thumbnails
will flip in and
turn to a video.
So that shows you how
you can embed the
videos within your UI.
And play and close them
programmatically.
-And moving along.
There is a simple player view
demo included as well.
Can you tell us when one might
want to include this code?
-Sure.
So Simple Player View is just
the simplest possible approach
to using the API and embedding
video into your app.
So this is just embedding
a simple player
view into the UI.
I have nothing else apart
from a text view.
But you can put whatever
you want above.
And it's just showing how simple
it is to embed it as a
player view.
And we also have the simple
player fragment, which is
basically--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: There are
three reasons why I actually
think this is a really
interesting show.
Number one, the API that
we were featuring
is extremely powerful.
So if you're building a mobile
application, and you are not
embedding YouTube content in
your application, take a look.
It's very easy to do.
And we went into details with
Ross McIlroy, who hopefully is
watching us right now from the
UK, where part of the show
took place.
The second reason is, this
show was actually kind of
challenging to film.
We were in two different
locations,
really around the world.
So I was in Mountain View, and
Ross was actually in our
London studio.
And we're trying to pretend like
we are actually operating
the same equipment together.
And it all kind of worked out.
Number three, actually there
were some challenges.
So we had very memorable
moments.
We had to film the show
twice, and then
edit it for many hours.
So it was painful, but
it was worth it.
And I really encourage
you to check out
that API if you haven't.
With that, I'll hand
it over to Ibrahim.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yes.
I actually picked as well from--
it was a Broadcast
Yourself video.
And I was talking about the
Live Streaming API.
And we wanted to give a demo
to show how it was easy to
just go to live.
And I wanted to stream from
my Android device.
But I was real scared, because
I was going a public network
that everyone was
already on it.
And we had an aha moment that
it's not going to work.
But it really worked.
And that was a great
moment for me.
Why don't we just take
a look and see it?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-In this.
And I will start streaming
right now.
And it looks like I
started streaming.
So let's see on the
YouTube website.
This time I will just click.
And my event is about
to start.
Let's give a few seconds.
-Give it a couple of seconds.
It looks like the demo gods
are being favorable today.
Can we blame the network?
-Sorry?
-Can we blame the network?
-Yeah, sure.
Why not?
-Give us a couple of seconds.
And--
-No.
I/O '13 was actually--
the question was, if
I was streaming to
I/O '13 or this event.
As I just did here, actually,
seemed to do a
live streaming event.
I/O '13 was when I used it
from my Java Eclipse.
So today I showed the Eclipse.
But you are free to use the
language of your choice, as
well as something
is happening.
And yep, you are live.
-There we go.
We should get the audience on.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah,
in this one, this
was our product manager.
He decided to cover me up with--
rather than not being
happy with me, saying, oh maybe
the network is not on in
this moment.
But as a side note, actually,
it makes my civic platform
more available, all the way down
to 100 subscribers now.
And I really encourage you to
use the Live Streaming API.
And we really want to see
amazing apps built on the Live
Streaming API.
And by saying that, I want
to hand it back to Ikai.
IKAI LAN: All right.
So everyone here has shown some
really cool videos with
some really good content.
One of my favorite I/O
talks is the one
Darryl was talking about.
So that's on our playlist.
And you can get to
our playlist at
youtube.com/youtubedev.
My favorite part from
that playlist is--
there a few different parts.
And Darryl and I debated a
little bit about that.
There was one bit where we're
talking about cute baby
annotations.
And there's another really funny
bit about Kim Jong Il.
So definitely, if you haven't
seen the semantic annotations
talk, I double recommend
that talk.
So I'm going to show you guys
another clip from I/O. There's
no meat in this content.
This is purely just fluff.
I'm only here for comic
relief, as this
clip will show you.
So why don't we go ahead
and run this clip?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So I've always wanted to be the
guy who gets to give away
all the goodies, right?
We call that the Oprah moment.
And today, I'm happy to announce
that you get a
YouTube, and you get a YouTube,
and you get a YouTube.
YouTubes for everyone
in this audience.
Good afternoon, everybody.
It's good to see your energy
level is still up.
I like that.
You've had a lot of learning
thrown at you.
And you're going to have some
more thrown at you today.
My name is Ikai Lan.
I'm a member of the YouTube
Developer Relations team.
I'm based out of
New York City.
Today we're going to be talking
about best practices
when working with mobile
platforms and the YouTube API.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
IKAI LAN: That's just the intro
to the I/O talk, where
I'm talking about mobile
best practices.
Which really is kind of a pile
on onto the show Yarek was
talking about, using the
Android player API.
So I was nervous at that
one for different
reasons then Ibrahim.
I can't blame the Wi-Fi
if my jokes fall flat.
So I think that's--
yeah, right?
So there you have it.
There are some of our
favorite moments.
It's really hard to pick.
So a little bit of ego there,
of what I call humble brag.
And that was my clip.
So Jeff.
JEFF POSNICK: It's been really
great having everybody in New
York for this show.
And I'd actually want
to reiterate
what Ikai had mentioned.
We put together a playlist that
collects all the videos
that we featured on this show.
So there's a link to that
playlist from our main
youtube.com/youtubedev
channel.
Be sure to subscribe
to that channel.
And also, I'd recommend
subscribing to
youtube.com/googledevelopers
as well.
We'll put video annotations on
this video, linking to all the
individual shows.
So that you could get to them
more easily when you're
watching this.
And just as always, going to
plug the fact that Google
Developer Relations is hiring.
I do not know that we have more
room in this studio for
another team member.
I guess that's kind
of a nice--
AMANDA: You need to build
a bigger studio.
JEFF POSNICK: It's the kind
of nice problems to solve.
To have such a big team that
we need more space.
So if you're interested in
learning more about what we
do, you could go to
developers.google.com/jobs.
And that's it for this
week's show.
It's been great having
everybody here.
And bye, everybody.